el aumento de la violencia llevó al
presidente de ecuador a tomar la
decisión he declarado estado de
excepción en las provincias del guayas
manabí y esmeraldas efectivo desde la
medianoche de hoy una medida que se
extenderá por al menos 60 días ahí se
movilizarán cuatro mil policías y cinco
mil militares y además regirá el toque
de queda nocturno para algunas
parroquias de localidades como durán no
si son en los puntos críticos
inicialmente en donde la policía tiene
la información en donde existe un mayor
índice delincuencial y posteriormente
conforme a las operaciones se vayan
dando se modificarán los sectores de
acuerdo a los resultados que se vayan
obteniendo
ecuador vive una ola de violencia desde
por lo menos hace un año según cifras
del ministerio de defensa la
delincuencia ha dejado mil 255 muertos
tan sólo en el primer cuatrimestre de
este año se ha hecho a todos nos afectan
terribles es terrible hasta nos afecta
la inseguridad ya no podemos estar en
lugares
como con facilidad como uno estaba ante
por ejemplo en caso de que tú vas a un
restaurant ya no se puede ahora compras
para llevar porque ya la inseguridad no
se puede
según el gobierno ecuatoriano el
incremento de la violencia está
directamente ligado al narcotráfico en
la zona vecino de colombia y perú los
mayores productores de cocaína en el
mundo 'ecuador ha servido como puerto de
salida de cargamentos hacia eeuu y
europa tan solo en lo que va del 2022
ecuador ha confiscado 75 toneladas de
droga además de los enfrentamientos en
las cárceles una situación que ha
azotado al país en repetidas ocasiones
desde febrero de 2021 han muerto 350
reos en enfrentamientos por el poder
entre organizaciones del narcotráfico
[Música]